bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles
nous sommes ensemble pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans cette
émission je vous emmène à molenbeek
saint jean une commune toute proche de
bruxelles depuis les attentats du 13
novembre à paris celle-ci se voir
présenter stigmatisés comme la capitale
du jihadisme en europe sur place les
habitants vivent très mal cette
étiquette et surtout les pouvoirs
publics et associations s'organisent
comment lutter contre la radicalisation
ce sera notre débat cette semaine mais
d'abord l'actualité la turquie de
nouveau frappé par le terrorisme ce
mardi dix personnes ont perdu la vie
dans un attentat suicide à sultanat met
face à la mosquée bleue et sainte-sophie
un quartier très touristique
la majorité des victimes sont des
touristes allemands et la piste de dèche
a très vite été une évidence
on écoute le premier ministre et le
président turc
je viens juste d'avoir une conversation
avec la chancelière angela merkel pour
exprimer mes condoléances aux citoyens
allemands qui ont perdu leur vie
voir la vidéo mais nous savons que
l'auteur de l'attaqué est un membre de
dèche
je veux réaffirmer que nous continuerons
le combat contre des ch avec la même
détermination à quoi celle de gmg chose
de lumineux
je condamne fermement cet attentat
terroriste qui a été commis par un
kamikaze d'origine syrienne dans le
centre touristique d'istanbul à susanna
maiolo de lundi le sait le rôle de
personnes ont malheureusement perdu la
vie ce monsieur bonjour à la mama sow
bonjour vous êtes président de la
délégation française du groupe ppe parti
populaire européen les républicains
quand vous voyez que une fois de plus la
turquie après avoir déjà été touché au
mois d'octobre dernier par le pire
attentat quasi de son histoire
et une fois de plus par des ch est-ce à
dire que la turquie a été trop
complaisante avec l'organisation
terroriste ou tout simplement elle paye
sa participation à la coalition
je crois que la turquie paye d'abord son
double ou son triple jeu dans les
affaires syriennes
elle n'a jamais eu une attitude très
clair ni vis-à-vis des partis qui se
combattent en syrie ni vis-à-vis de nous
en ce qui concerne notamment le très
douloureux problème des réfugiés
cet attentat en tout cas montrent que
maintenant clairement la turquie est
obligé de s'engager à fond dans le
combat contre des sèche ce qui n'a pas
été vraiment le cas jusqu'à présent
est ce que vous pensez au vu de l'année
2015 qu'on a traversé des risques
d'attentats des attentats qu'on a connu
à paris sur dans d'autres villes du
territoire européen les menaces sur
bruxelles notamment
est-ce que vous pensez que 2015 n'a été
ne sera qu'une répétition finalement de
2016 à ce qu'on est prêt à affronter
cette menace
il faut qu'on le soit et notamment parce
que des ch est en train de commencer à
connaître ses premières défaites
militaires sérieuse sur le terrain et en
irak et en syrie
et donc la tentation peut être grande
pour les dirigeants de dèche qui ont
besoin de montrer pour leur propagande
et pour leurs recrutements qu'au
contraire il continue de gagner de
remporter des victoires 36 ans va être
grande de compenser en quelque sorte en
multipliant ce genre d'attentât chez
nous donc nous devons être vigilants
calme déterminé courageux efficace il ya
une autre crise que l'europe traverse
depuis déjà maintenant plusieurs mois
c'est la crise des réfugiés
on a vu dernièrement que suède et
danemark avaient rétabli leurs contrôles
aux frontières
avant de vous écouter sur cette question
petit retour en arrière
comme un symbole l'année 2016 en europe
débute par le retour des frontières
dépassé par l'afflux de migrants
la suède a décidé de rétablir les
contrôles des voyageurs sur le pont
tunnel de l'oresund entre malmö et
copenhague au danemark
il faut désormais présenter
systématiquement une pièce d'identité
pour espérer passer
une situation qui inquiète les usagers
qui évoque un nouveau mur de berlin est
réticent à cette clôture de deux mètres
de haut et des 375 mètres de long et
bien on l'a et le nouveau mur de berlin
et d'autres l'ont appelé le nouveau
rideau de fer
c'est vraiment mauvais parce que ça
montre qu'il ya désormais il frontière
entre la suède et le danemark que nous
n'avions pas l'habitude de voir
auparavant et cela détruit l'intégration
inquiets de voir des milliers de
réfugiés rester sur son sol le danemark
a donc lui aussi rétabli les frontières
avec l'allemagne l'allemagne qui
accueille à elle seule un million de
réfugiés sont et ému schengen est en
danger a déclaré le ministère allemand
des affaires étrangères
car à l'instar de la suède et du
danemark une dizaine de pays d'europe
ont d'ores et déjà rétablies des
contrôles aux frontières voire ont érigé
des clôtures anti migrants alors
schengen est il mort
alain lamassoure vous diriez à l'instar
du ministère des affaires étrangères
allemand que schengen est juste en
danger ou est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
une mort de schengen moi je n'aime pas
employer le mot de schengen parce que
ces empreintes d'une très grande
confusion par exemple on vient de parler
du danemark le danemark n'est pas dans
shine est donc dire nous donne marque
établie des frontières il y avait des
contrôles aux frontières théorique qui
le rend maintenant pratique qu'est ce
qui est en jeu dans cette affaire c'est
une crise qui est infiniment plus grave
que le terrorisme parce que ce qui est
en jeu c'est un des fondements majeurs
d'union européenne et le bénéfice majeur
pour les 500 millions de citoyens
européens que représente le fait de
pouvoir circuler librement en europe
ce qui est clair dans cette crise
migratoire ce que personne ne dit c'est
que le repli sur soi le chacun pour soi
la tentation qui existe partout de dire
je vais me protéger de tout ça en
enfermant mon pays
derrière des contrôles et même derrière
des barbelés des murs c'est un échec
absolu c'est un leurre
au mieux c'est ridicule au pire c'est
honteux du point de vue humanitaire
alors la hongrie est fière de ce entouré
de barbelés
elle le fait que renvoyé le problème aux
croître les croates font la même chose
ils renvoient slovène
les slovènes faire la même chose il
renvoie l'autriche et alors donc premier
enseignement à tirer c'est que la
solution de la maîtrise de ce flux qui
prend l'ampleur d'un exode migratoires
et ne peut être qu'européenne
mais il faut qu'elles soient pleinement
européenne c'est à dire que en
contrepartie de l'ouverture des
frontières à l'intérieur de l'espace
européen contrôle non nés à l'extérieur
mérite un véritable contre les fontes
extérieur avec des gardes frontières
européens qu'on va enfin mettre en place
maintenant que nous ayons aussi la même
politique est une politique énergique en
mobilisant tous les moyens de l'union
les moyens financiers mais aussi loin
diplomatique éventuellement dans
certains cas les moyens militaires pour
agir vis-à-vis des pays d'origine de ces
migrations ou dpi de 30 salariés ont
lavé comme la turquie
mais la turquie justement on voit que on
a offert à la turquie la possibilité de
se voir octroyer 3 milliards d'euros au
titre de l'âge
gestion de la crise des réfugiés pour
contenir nos frontières la commission
européenne a indiqué encore cette
semaine que les résultats étaient
insuffisants on voit encore des milliers
de personnes arrivées chaque jour
notamment en allemagne
question pratique est-ce que c'est à des
pays étrangers à l'union de sous traiter
afin de prendre en charge les frontières
extérieures et la sécurité de ses
frontières extérieures
le problème à la turquie n'est pas du
tout celui là le problème turquie et
linverse quelle est la raison pour
laquelle nous serions obligés
d'accueillir en france ou en allemagne
des victimes de la guerre civile
syrienne à la place des pays voisins de
la syrie qui sont oui mais vide mais là
lamassoure la turquie et notamment la
jordanie au liban
enfin garde le plus gros en fait
absolument rien et ça s'est bien passé
de 2 millions et demi en turquie étant
donné que le voeu de la plus grande
partie des syriens qui sont obligés de
fuir leur pays en proie à la guerre
civile
c'est d'y revenir le jour où la guerre
civile est terminée
nous devons être beaucoup plus ferme
vis-à-vis des tur alors là mon ma
question c'est on a promis 3 milliards
d'euros à la turquie pour justement
l'aider à la prise en charge de cette
crise on a déclaré il ya encore la
commission européenne ya encore quelques
jours que du coup la révision
pluriannuel du budget européen qui est
pour la première fois de l'histoire a
été en baisse en 2014 qui était prévu
pour cette année serait repoussée signer
dié comment est-ce qu'on va financer
tout ça lamassoure lé renforcement de
frontex et gardes frontières alors je
rappelle que le parlement dans par ma
voix j'étais président de la commission
des budgets au moment où on négocier le
cadre budgétaire des années actuelles
2014 2020 il ya deux ans avait mis en
garde solennellement jeu en disant si ce
budget en baisse nous ne pourrons pas
faire face aux nécessités d'une
politique commune de l'asile
d'immigration qui figurait déjà dans
notre programme électoral
la bonne nouvelle c'est que la crise est
elle le manque d'argent est telle que
pour la première fois à la fois le
président de la commission européenne
jean claude juncker mais aussi quelqu'un
d'aussi
ardent à défendre les économies
budgétaires que le ministre allemand des
finances la ccac c'est l'envol bangchui
bleus commencent à dire nous avons
besoin de ressources supplémentaires
pour faire face à ses besoins
radicalement nouveau et donc nous devons
mettre à profit l'année 2016 pour voir
comment donnions à l'europe ont dit non
à l'europe les moyens et peut-être des
ressources attaque j'ai voulu l'aider et
de nouvelles ressources propres les
moyens d'exécuter les décisions qui ont
été prises pour l'instant l'europe
je te dirais est un géant juridique est
un géant législatif et 1,1 budgétaire
ouais et nous prétendons financer une
politique mondiale avec des pourboires
nous consacrons aujourd'hui que 1% de
notre richesse totale produite chaque
année se rappelle le produit intérieur
brut
ouais alors que nos états nos politiques
nationales consomment plus de 40% du
produit intérieur brut
et vous il faut rééquilibrer écouter
merci beaucoup à la lamassoure de nous
avoir éclairé sur cette question
nous on continue après les attentats du
13 novembre à paris l'europe découvrait
médusé l'existence de la ville de
molenbeek saint jean dans la banlieue de
bruxelles
celle ci s'est vu affublé du titre de
capitale européenne du jihadisme les
auteurs des attentats ayant séjourné
jérôme bonnard est retourné sur place à
la rencontre des associations et des
services qui lutte contre la
radicalisation
chaque semaine le rendez vous
immanquable des molènes b quoi le grand
marché de la place communale
bachir et éducateurs dans ce quartier
populaire où il a grandi c'est ça oui
c'est la vie les gens se vivent
normalement quoi en bonne intelligence
oui totalement quoi et ça c'est la
majorité des habitants de la commune
et pourtant en novembre dernier la
réputation de molenbeek s'est
brutalement ternie aux yeux du monde
entier
pour beaucoup la commune est devenue
l'épicentre du terrorisme islamiste
j'ai l'impression que le ciel nous tombe
sur la tête comme dire astérix et c'est
vrai qu'on s'attendait pas déferlement
pareil quoi c'est clair on essaie de se
remettre
ce n'est pas encore tout à fait ça mais
oui je suis triste pour ce boulot pour
l'image du quartier de ce qu'il est
réellement molenbeek saint jean et ses
cent mille habitants sont à dix minutes
du centre ville de bruxelles en tramway
entre les deux un canal cette frontière
naturelle symbolise aujourd'hui la mise
à l'écart de la seconde commune la plus
pauvre de belgique
ici le chômage frappe une jeunesse
désoeuvrée chez les 18 25 ans la moitié
sont sans emploi un cocktail explosif
qui peut favoriser la radicalisation
elle est très difficile à cerner
si elle est propre maman et parents de
jeunes qui ont fait ses conneries n'ont
pas anticipé n'ont pas senti que ça
pouvait arriver
comment nous personne lambda pouvons le
savoir et s'ils ont des mauvaises
intentions dans ce sens et nous le
dirons pas c'est pourquoi la
municipalité a créé une cellule de
déradicalisation 2014
actuellement une trentaine de familles
sont suivies par des psychologues et des
sociologues
le constat est souvent le même il ya
toujours quelque chose qui s'est jouée
au sein de la famille qu'il peut y avoir
un conflit
il peut y avoir une séparation un d'une
relation bruce qui s'est mal terminée
pour lequel le jeune un certain âge avec
cette chercher des réponses nous posant
la famille mais à l'extérieur il peut
être au bout de ses copains bas au
niveau 6 les personnes plus malveillant
qui vont essayer de l'endoctriner
nous retrouvons bachir dans les locaux
de son association le foyer
au début c'est bien je comprends c'est
le rythme il est acceptable et abuser
des ados il en a accompagné des
centaines un travail de terrain précieux
sa pédagogie la culture du langage et
l'éducation
pour lui c'est l'antidote absolue au
radicalisme
si on veut parler de radicalisme rome ce
qui a ému ignorance ces jeunes là parce
qu'ils n'ont pas la culture est en tout
cas qu'il n'arrive pas à les ouvrir un
livre pour s'informer de ce qui est réel
et ce qui ne l'est pas au lieu de mettre
du fric dans le répressif c'est à dire
police armée mettons du fric dans le
savoir dans une autre pièce
les plus grands eux dénoncent cette
injustice qu'ils subissent souvent dans
une commune où les dotations de l'état
sont en baisse constante
on donne pas c'est la chance aux jeunes
c'est pour ça que ces jeunes là sont un
peu perdus un peu court mais dans la
société
et quand il trouve une occasion de fuir
abeilles vont fuir parce qu'on leur
promette une belge et ailleurs
maintenant une personne qui a un travail
qui est une crise sociale qui a été
acquis à tous ici je pense pas qu'il va
aller qui va se radicaliser
du côté des mosquées on refuse les
amalgames dans une ville trop hâtivement
présenté comme un ghetto islamiste et je
n'essaie de molex sont des jeunes qui ne
fréquentent pas les mosquées
ce sont des jeunes qui ont été recrutés
qui ont été engagés sur les réseaux
sociaux et aussi par des réseaux mafieux
qui utilisent l'islam à d'autres femmes
qui instrumentalisent l'islam
que se passe-t-il réellement à molenbeek
les programme de déradicalisation sont
ils efficaces
la belgique at elle pris conscience trop
tard du phénomène dans le débat
politique
la question est posée il n'y a pas eu
assez tôt une approche répressive de
de ce phénomène il ya eu au nom du
multiculturalisme une très grande
tolérance devant ces mouvements radicaux
devant des mouvements salafistes demandé
mouvement extrêmement extrémistes qui
sont devenus au bout d'un temps pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux d'entre eux
violent il faut qu'il y ait une double
critique à la fois au sein des
communautés musulmanes mais il faut
qu'ils aient aussi une critique de la
société
qu'avons nous rater en matière
d'intégration sociale qu'avons nous
rater en matière de lutte contre les
discriminations pour que ces enfants qui
sont nos enfants en ville à se retourner
contre le pays qui les a vu grandir
depuis 2012 plus de 400 belges auraient
quitté leur pays pour combattre en syrie
ou en irak
c'est deux fois plus que la france par
million d'habitants
comment lutter contre la radicalisation
des jeunes européens je vais en débattre
tout de suite avec jean marie cavada
bonjour je revois tous bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe libéral
démocrate et marc tarabella en face de
vous bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
belge socialistes démocrates marc
tarabella ma question ma première
question quand on entend alain destexhe
qui dit
on a été trop loin dans le
multiculturalisme on n'a pas su voir est
ce que la belgique est passé à côté d'un
problème
la belgique et la saint guirons la
commune de molenbeek ont essayé et le
portrait de bachir est exemple hâtif de
ce qu'on a essayé de faire de ce qu'on a
fait sur le terrain pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait cette tolérance cette
éducation à la citoyenneté dans les
quartiers on a beaucoup investi dans ce
domaine là mais il avait aussi mais sans
doute pas assez mais je pense que ça a
été fait malheureusement ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est raboter les budgets
qui sont dévolues à cette éducation qui
doit être permanente au profit d'un
budget qui est nécessaire aussi la
sécurité
ça me paraît évident et là on a raté
probablement un épisode et je peux
partager c'est qu'effectivement on a
peut être laissé trop à un moment donné
se propager un discours rampant de
radicalisme
moi je le dis clairement quand je vois à
bruxelles dans certains quartiers on n'a
pas vu ce marché molenbeek parce qu'on
voit une population je dirais normal qui
fait son marché donc c'est une dans
certains quartiers de bruxelles
il ya des femmes qui sont voilées de
manière amicale un groupe qui s'appelle
sharia4belgium oui j'aimerais qu'ils
aient démantelé mais quand même ça lui
on arrive et vous voulez dire que moi je
suis on allait quand je vois dans
certains quartiers de bruxelles des
femmes at le niqab c'est intolérable
c'est incompatible avec la démocratie
je ne vois pas sahara à banias
casablanca ni à bas coût sont des pays
où la religion musulmane est largement
majoritaire et donc il y a eu mais ne
nous trompons pas aujourd'hui elle
radicalistes sont pas nécessairement des
gens a qu'une grande barbe c'est aussi
des jeunes qui sortent en boîte qui se
fond effectué sur internet convertie en
moyenne à internet il faut en parler
le fait de on a un cocktail détonnant à
bruxelles d'une région qui a difficile
de vivre économiquement parce qu'il ya
peu d'activités
enfin il ya les activités
administratives frères activités pour
les jeunes et à une population qui
augmente qui est désordre et parfois
laissés pour compte
alors effectivement il ya des mouvements
éducatif mais c'est un cocktail
détonnant de ne pas avoir d'espoir dans
la vie et d'être radicaliser en tout cas
séduit par des gens qui savent si
j'attends qu'ils ont d'attention pour
vous par internet internet aussi c'est
effectivement
le dis clairement le reporter jean marie
cavada est ce que dira que ce sont juste
des gens désoeuvrés c'est suffisant
quand on a 30 % de gens qui sont des
convertis qui à la base n'ont rien à
voir avec la religion de l'islam et qui
en plus donc apprennent sur internet et
enfin qui viennent deux catégories
socioprofessionnelles type classe
moyenne voire csp + je crois qu'il ya la
réalité physique on vient d'en voir un
exemple dans votre reportage et puis il
ya la réalité numérique je vais
commencer par celle là il faut
absolument que sous cette pression
violence qui s'exerce contre les pays
européens est d'ailleurs pas que
européen il faut absolument que
pourvoyeur d'accès face renforcer leurs
équipes de contrôle efface la police du
nettoyage de la toile et de ce qu'ils
promettent aux fournisseurs d'accès de
faire la police bien entendu j'entends
des sottises du genre le net et neutre
sa neutralité mais ça veut rien dire du
tout il n'est pas neutre comme un
journal n'est pas neutre comme une télé
n'est pas neutre comme une radio n'est
pas neutre ce qu'ils sont des médias
doivent avoir une responsabilité
éditoriale
d'ailleurs plusieurs plusieurs démarches
ont eu lieu le ministre français de
l'intérieur était allé voir le vice
président de facebook si ma mémoire est
bonne pour essayer de convenir de cette
chose
en effet on voit bien qu'il ya des
efforts qui commencent à s'organiser du
côté n'est ce pas il faut il faut ça
paraît dérisoire finalement on s'est pas
juste on éradique en fait le discours
sur internet qu'on va éradiquer la
radicale je vous ai dit keith deux
choses et ceci est seulement la première
la deuxième c'est en effet un immense
échec d'intégration de nos pays a pas
que la belgique la france comme vous le
savez il ya eu la sphère espagnol même
si c'était largement des en 2004 et la
sphère britannia 2005 qui était
largement des gens importés en
grande-bretagne s'était aussi des
britanniques
bref on voit bien qu un immense échec
d'intégration de ces gens pourquoi parce
que je pense que les états on se sont
abandonnés ont laissé monter les
religions comme un des éléments de la
communauté la religion n'a rien à faire
dans les affaires d'état
et c'est stupéfiant de voir dans ce
millénaire qui a maintenant 16 ans de
voir combien les religions sont montés
dans d'en haut marche des affaires de
l'état aujourd'hui
on voit bien qu'il manque des moyens sur
les questions économiques il faut de
l'éducation ok je vais poser une
première question qui et comment on
finance à sachant que on se rappelle une
crise de la dette qui a été monstrueuse
pour les états européens premièrement et
deuxièmement la question sécuritaire on
va voter le pnr européens la semaine
prochaine en session au parlement à
strasbourg on nous vend des portiques de
sécurité vous l'avez vu vous même quand
vous prenez le thalys le retour des
contrôles aux frontières etc
quand on sait que on a été attaqué sur
notre sol par des ressortissants
européens est ce que c'est pas un
emplâtre sur une jambe de bois marc
tarabella
il est clair qu'on doit avoir conscience
que les radicaux ne viennent pas de
l'extérieur les terroristes potentiels
ce sont souvent des jeunes qui ont la
nationalité française belge
les séances des nationalités peut-être
bon ça c'est c'est un problème il faut
essayer d'attaquer le problème à la
racine et il a il a de multiples il ya
des multiples facettes l'éducation sete
fondamentale la sécurité est aussi
quelque chose de fondamental le citoyen
il a le droit de vivre en sécurité
elle argumente un droit fondamental moi
je ne suis pas pour qu'on diminue la
sécurité il faut il faut la renforcer
pour ce commet marc tarabella on voit
bien que le pnr en l'occurrence qu'on a
voté en fête aurait été proprement
inutile dans le cas des attentats
français du 13 novembre
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on a peur on
voit bien que les services de
renseignement européens ont eu beaucoup
de mal à à ce communiqué ne serait ce
que des informations jean marie cavada
d'abord je n'ai je ne suis pas d'accord
avec la formulation de votre question
sur votre respect parce que même quand
il s'agit de nationaux ils sont partis
en syrie
la compagne ou l'ami de coulibaly en
france est parti à barcelone puis
ensuite à istanbul et donc que si ça
avait fonctionné
la réservation de billets auraient
permis de l'arrêter à orly ou bien à
l'aéroport de madrid où elle a transité
de façon à ce que les choses soient
vraiment maîtriser ça c'est une première
chose des comptes les frontières
extérieures de schengen doivent être
totalement renforcer on n'y a aucun état
qui ne se protègent pas dire que nous
les messins qui a acquis et arrive à
cette catastrophe
les états membres de l'union ont refusé
depuis une douzaine d'années à l'union
les moyens de contrôler les frontières
et à frontex les moyens de patrouille et
pour trouver des vies en méditerranée
de moyens ça suffit cette propagande qui
consiste à dire c'est l'europe c'est
l'europe et l'europe
laissez les gouvernements qui donc a
voulu au motif de souveraineté amène t
on enfin d'accord matin on en voit là il
ya une deuxième chose les moyens du
renseignement doivent être d'abord des
moyens humains
il ya une troisième chose ces choses là
aurait dû être depuis très longtemps
depuis les attentats de madrid organisé
dans les pays de l'union
de façon à ce qu'on fasse un bon
équilibre avec des moyens efficaces de
renseignements et de protection
policière et de protection de liberté
individuelle parce que ça va ensemble ne
faisons pas le patriot act que nous
avons nous européens beaucoup condamnent
et donc l'état d'urgence par exemple en
france
l'état d'urgence est une nécessité à un
moment donné mais le pérenniser mais le
pérenniser peut amener à des dangers
pour une raison simple je ne suspecte
pas le gouvernement actuel d'être
mortifère est d'avoir des velléités
d'autorité antidémocratique
mais savez-vous qui demain peut diriger
le pays est ce que c'est à nous de
fournir a déjà un certain le moyen je
dirais d'exercer une autorité qui est
fatigué je dirais tu pourrais avoir des
tentations fascisante
il faut faire très attention à tout ça
alors marc tarabella là dessus je me
pose une question c'est qu'effectivement
il faut bien qu'il faut on voit qu'il
faut renforcer frontex
on voit qu'il faut renforcer le
renseignement européens ont du moins les
gens informations ça nécessite de
l'humain 1 parce que s'il ne s'agit pas
juste de récupérer de la date un des
données non est-ce qu'on a les moyens de
nos ambitions est ce que finalement on
ne risque pas de se retrouver dans la
même posture en 2016 à se dire on s'est
pas donné les moyens dont il faut se
donner les moyens les moyens il
réellement ils sont là le budget
européen est là chaque état membre doit
aussi faire un effort pour des priorités
là je dis vivre en sécurité de la
société
c'est évidemment une priorité sur la
ligne par exemple françois hollande qui
dit pacte de stabilité va à l'encontre
du pacte de sécurité
oui il a raison il a totalement raison
parce qu on s'empêche d'investir dans
des priorités que la société publique en
tout cas doit de se doter la sécurité en
études n'y a pas que il ya l'éducation
aujourd'hui on se prive d'investir dans
ce qui est fondamental et donc pacte de
stabilité
moi j'ai suffisamment critiqué parce
qu'on fait croire vous avez parlé vous
même de la crise de la dette la crise de
la dette n'existe pas dans tous les pays
c'est même une minorité des pays qui
sont hyper endetté la crise vient du
monde bancaire qui joue plus son rôle
on va pas refaire l'histoire ce n'est
pas le débat du jour ce qu'il faut faire
c'est surtout mettre en oeuvre les
moyens qui existent déjà quand j'entends
sarkozy dira schengen est mort c'est une
erreur fondamentale schengen est un
droit fondamental de circulation à
l'intérieur de l'espace
il faut renforcer quand jean marie
cavada l'a dit la sécurité aux
frontières le contrôle aux frontières
extérieures de l'union
mais dans l'union des contrôles existent
schengen prévoit les contrôles on doit
contrôler les citoyens européens quand
il circule dans l'espace très justement
à faire sauter les verrous par exemple
du pacte de stabilité se dire puisque là
on est face à des enjeux absolument
énorme et c'est pas vraiment le sujet
parce que les pays les plus endettés du
monde ne sont pas sur le continent
européen à celle japon et c'est les
états unis au japon près de 200% les
états unis largement au dessus de 120 ou
130 % fin bref c'est pas le sujet le
plus je dirais le plus le plus dangereux
maintenant il faut se donner les moyens
les états aussi devraient faire des
efforts pour ne pas pas dépenser
d'argent inutile dans leur train de vie
dans la surabondance je dirais
administratives et autres mais je dirais
que s'arrête à la marge pour l'instant
la chose la plus importante
elle est dans deux niveaux que les états
prennent des moyens de de renseignement
des moyens de contrôle qu'ils prennent
des moyens préventifs d'éducation
massifs massif d'un plan marshall qu'il
nous faut massif si ça va pas là c'est
là qu'il faut aller
et puis je voudrais dire aussi une chose
qu'il se montre un peu plus intelligents
les états quand il vienne siéger ici à
lyon parce que ils ont dit partout que
le pnr été freinée par le parlement et
le pnr que nous avons il n'est pas
complet il aurait fallu rendre leur
échange d'informations automatique
obligatoire est régulièrement mise à
jour avec une cellule de centralisation
des informations des robes douces des
services de renseignement européens ici
à bruxelles où ailleurs en tout cas une
cellule 1 comme on a un schengen
une cellule qu'on doit quand on doit
compléter la protection il faut que le
renseignement soit échangé les tueurs
belges sont venus en france des tueurs
français sont venus en belgique
voilà la démonstration qui me semblent
indiscutables
donc là une mutualisation communautaire
des moyens de renseignements et de lutte
anti l'urgence finalement bien jonathan
durant sa nuit et c'est pas tout il faut
aussi maintenant donner un grand coup de
pied dans la fourmilière pour que les
moyens judiciaires accompagné moyens
policiers parce que ça aussi
marc tarabella
jean- marié va vivre une agence seriat
de récolter deux points si c'est pour ne
rien en faire si ce n'est pas pour les
et les échanger et aujourd'hui on va
voter un pnr on va voter 28 pnr
nationaux ça ne suffit pas et absurde
c'est vraiment absurde
écoutez ce sera le mot de la fin c'est
absurde mais malheureusement absurde le
pnr parce que dix marques d'accor merci
pour la précision
merci beaucoup monsieur de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce sujet merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis rendez vous la semaine
prochaine avec un match à venir à
strasbourg chao et merci